a Florida uber driver who claimed
self-defense in a new stand-your-ground
controversy will not face charges for
the deadly shooting of another driver
the Polk County Sheriff's Office
released the ubers dashcam video from
the confrontation Tuesday morning
it shows Jason Boeing approached the car
apparently and threatened the driver
before he was shot
Tony de copal is here with how the
encounter unfolded Tony good morning
good morning the Sheriff's Office says
Jason Polk thought his girlfriend was
inside that over when he tried to force
it off the road and the deadly shooting
occurred the Polk County Sheriff
meanwhile is calling it a classic case
of stand-your-ground this is a
justifiable homicide all day long Polk
County Sheriff Grady Judd says the
evidence shows the uber driver Robert
Westlake acted in self-defense
Jason Polk stopped in front of Westlake
got out of his truck and pulled out a
cell phone like a handgun as he
approached the car Westlake called 911
to revive Polk he ran the off-road
vehicle I couldn't get away he came
towards me
shouted he's got a pistol reached for
his waistband I'm applying pressure to
the room he police say it all started at
a bar in Dundee about 45 miles south of
Orlando Boca and his estranged
girlfriend Jessica Mazzarella were
drinking here when they got into a fight
Bach left but was still watching the bar
from a truck he borrowed from a friend
police say Mazzarella was texting with
Polk while also helping a bartender get
an intoxicated customer into an uber
boat followed that who were thinking
Mazzarella was inside but she wasn't
he told her he planned on assaulting the
driver but what police say Boake did not
know was the driver Westlake was a
recent Police Academy graduate and armed
with a legal concealed handgun here's a
message for the hotheads of the
community don't do that stuff
good people carry guns and they will
shoot you a lot graveyard dead sheriff
may have a point there this of course is
not the first controversial
stand-your-ground incident
Florida earlier this month the man was
charged with manslaughter after police
initially declined to charge him in a
parking lot shooting and there is of
course the Trayvon Martin case the
unarmed 17 year old was shot and killed
in 2012 by George Zimmerman who was
acquitted sheriff Judd really speaking
the truth there about trying to warn
people about this yet some Florida
wisdom there all right Tony thank you